und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und Dunja Hayali
schönen guten Abend der 24 Februar 2022
hat sicher das Leben aller Ukrainer
verändert der Mann an dem man das wohl
gut ablesen kann ist wo Leute mir
selenski seit 574 Tagen verteidigt sich
sein Land gegen den Aggressor aus
Russland und seit genauso vielen Tagen
ist der ukrainische Präsident den zuvor
ja viele belächelt haben im Dauereinsatz
Durchhaltevermögen hat er damit aber
auch sein Land weiter standhalten kann
braucht er Unterstützung weitere
Unterstützung und um die warb er in den
letzten 48 Stunden bei der UNO
Vollversammlung es gab in New York
etliche treffen und etliche Hände wurden
geschüttelt auch die deutsche Hand die
zweitgrößter Geber von Militärhilfen ist
mehr gibt nur die US-amerikanische und
daher war das Treffen heute wohl auch
das Wichtigste
der Besuch bei seinem loyalsten und
mächtigsten Unterstützer Präsident
beiden wird selensky hier in wenigen
Minuten ein weiteres militärisches
Hilfspaket ankündigen das
Luftabwehrsysteme und andere Waffen
enthalten soll doch zuvor im Kongress
musste silensky Überzeugungsarbeit
leisten wie in der Bevölkerung insgesamt
lässt auch die Unterstützung einiger
mächtiger republikanischer Abgeordneter
nach Einzelgespräche hinter
verschlossenen Türen eine geht einer
kommt um Skeptiker zu überzeugen denn er
braucht Ihre Hilfe doch viele von ihnen
fragen wo ist der Weg zum Sieg wofür die
vielen Milliarden
selenski hat am Ende nichts in der Hand
gibt sich aber zuversichtlich
wir hatten großartige Gespräche ich bin
ihnen allen sehr dankbar den
Journalisten den Senatoren dem Kongress
dafür dass Sie uns helfen wir haben über
viele Details gesprochen aber das bleibt
unter uns tut mir leid
der Kongress soll weitere 26 Milliarden
Dollar für die Ukraine bewilligen doch
die Republikaner führen einen
erbitterten Streit um den Haushalt
einige wollen auf einen shutdown zu
steuern so könnten die Ukraine Hilfen
zum Kollateralschaden politischer Renke
Spiele werden vor allem die Trump
Marionetten sagen nein
wir geben kein Geld mehr wir werden
unser Land nicht in den Dritten
Weltkrieg mit Russland Schlafwandeln
lassen
der Sprecher des Repräsentantenhauses
konnte nur mit deren Stimmen seinen
Posten ergattern hängt an ihrem
Gängelband und verzweifelt jetzt an
ihrem Extremismus
das ist ein ganz neues Konzept den
ganzen Laden einfach abfackeln zu wollen
das funktioniert doch nicht
andere traditionelle Republikaner werfen
der beiden Regierung vor nicht genug zu
tun sie üben Druck aus der Ukraine auch
die Marschflugkörper attackhams mit
größerer Reichweite zu überlassen um
diese Lenski auch den
US-Verteidigungsminister bittet doch auf
die Frage warum er die attackhams nicht
frei gibt
von Minister Austin nur Schweigen so
wird selensky später nach Hause reisen
mit großen Hoffnungen und großen Sorgen
denn wirklich beruhigen kann Ihnen der
Besuch hier nicht
tja reden ist gut handeln und liefern
ist besser das dürfte die Gedankenwelt
des ukrainischen Präsidenten sein zwar
sind die Marschflugkörper vom Typ
attackens nicht vom Tisch aber wir haben
es gerade gehört sie liegen halt auch
nicht auf dem Tisch der US-Präsident hat
noch keine Entscheidung getroffen
genauso wenig wie der deutsche
Bundeskanzler in Bezug auf Taurus in
diese Hängepartie rauscht eine Nachricht
aus Polen diese lensky sicher nicht
erfreut hat Polen will die
Waffenlieferungen an die Ukraine auf
bereits abgeschlossene Verträge
beschränken über die Gründe Natalie
Steger
Bilder aus besseren Tagen Polen und die
Ukraine seit an seit kaum ein Land hat
wie Polen so getrommelt für die
Unterstützung von Kiew seit Beginn des
russischen angriffskriegs auf das
Nachbarland und dann das
Regierungschef moraviewski gestern Abend
wir liefern keine Waffen mehr an die
Ukraine weil wir uns jetzt selbst mit
den modernsten Waffen ausstatten werden
polnische Waffen sollen künftig nicht
ins Nachbarland das sorgt international
für Aufsehen aber bestehende
waffenverträge würden noch erfüllt
werden so die peace offenbar bemüht um
internationale Schaden zu begrenzt
also was jetzt für
Oppositionsführer Tusk in der heißen
Wahlkampfphase ist die Sache klar
der Ukraine politische Messer in den
Rücken zu rammen während sie schlachten
an der Front aus trägt ist ein
moralischer und geopolitischer Skandal
nur weil es sich für die peace
wahlkampftechnisch auszahlen soll
es geht um die Macht im Land am 15
Oktober sind Parlamentswahlen laut
Umfragen muss die peace um ihre absolute
Mehrheit fürchten und Fisch zunehmend
bei noch rechteren Parteien
die Pies konkurriert gerade mit der
parteikonföderatia um skeptischere
Wähler die negativ gegenüber der Ukraine
eingestellt sind daher diese
retoriker
Warschau streitet seit Wochen mit Kiew
über ukrainische Getreidelieferungen in
die EU die polnische Regierung will das
mit aller Macht verhindern die
heimischen Bauern demonstrativ
vorgetreide aus der Ukraine schützen
gegen den Willen der EU das Verhältnis
von Kiew und Warschau deswegen schwer
belastet der ukrainische Präsident
zuletzt in New York vor der
unfallversammlung
es ist alarmieren zu sehen wie einige
unserer Freunde in Europa ein
politisches Theater der Solidarität
spielen und einen Thriller um Getreide
machen
aber faktisch helfen Sie dem Akteur aus
Moskau eine Bühne zubereiten
die Liebe war schaust zu Kiew ist
abgekühlt wegen des getreidestreits wenn
der Ertrinkende uns mit Unterwasser
zieht wird er keine Hilfe bekommen
deshalb müssen wir uns um unsere eigenen
Interessen kümmern
der Tonfall der peace wird immer
nationaler Polen first und sei es auf
Kosten der Ukraine der Kurs ist durchaus
riskant den Warschau sorgt für
Irritationen in der westlichen Koalition
für die Ukraine
ja und heute Abend meldete sich der
Präsident Polens zu Wort offenbar
versucht er die Aussagen seines
Ministerpräsidenten wieder einzufangen
und spricht von einem Missverständnis
schauen wir jetzt nach Aserbaidschan
dessen Präsident hat die Menschen in
Bergkarabach ja immer wieder als Hunde
bezeichnet die man verjagen müsse daher
ist die Befürchtung der Armenier auch
groß das genau das passieren wird
nachdem was passiert ist vor zwei Tagen
startete Aserbaidschan eine wie das Land
es nannte spezialoperation um die
Souveränität wieder herzustellen und
nachdem die armenischen Kämpfer dann
gestern ihre Waffen niederlegten wurde
der Militäreinsatz auch als erfolgreich
verbucht sprich das autokratisch
regierte Aserbaidschan übernimmt die
Kontrolle über die Enklave der Karabach
gehört völkerrechtlich zu Aserbaidschan
wird aber mehrheitlich von Armenien
bewohnt was mit denen jetzt passiert ist
fraglich
so klingt das wenn Waffenstillstand
herrscht in Bergkarabach
am Vormittag hören die Menschen in der
Hauptstadt der Schüsse doch sie
reagieren kaum noch ohnehin sind die
Straßen fast leer
Slavka und David haben in einer Kirche
Zuflucht gefunden es herrscht Krieg
sagen die Kinder deshalb sind wir hier
Oma Rosa ruft von ihrer trage alles ist
kaputt ihr vorläufiges zu Hause ist ein
Gotteshaus
so sieht das aus wenn ein zwergenstart
den die Welt in 32 Jahren niemals
anerkannt hat abgewickelt wird
Evakuierung nennen das die russischen
Friedenstruppen doch ob diese Menschen
jemals Frieden finden dass es doch heute
die große Frage
sie flüchten weil sie zu Hause
Vertreibung und Gewalt fürchten durch
den Feind Aserbaidschan doch zunächst
geht es für sie auf eine russische
Militärbasis denn auch ihr Mutterland
armenien hat weder Geld noch Platz für
Sie deshalb warten an der Grenze die
armenischen Angehörigen der
eingesperrten vergebens
am Morgen kommen in der Stadt Sieger und
Besiegte zusammen also bei Jan lädt eine
Delegation von Karabach Armenien zu
Verhandlungen über das Schicksal der
Zivilbevölkerung 120.000 Menschen die
hungern während sie hier reden
ergebnislos von früheren Anführern
kommen Durchhalteparolen im
Nachrichtendienst Telegramm
eine Heimat und ein Staat werden nur
durch harte Arbeit geschaffen durch
Jahrhunderte lange Arbeit und wir sind
diese Arbeit den vergangenen und den
zukünftigen Generationen schuldig für
die Erhaltung unseres Vaterlandes
unseres Staates
in Armeniens Hauptstadt Eriwan
demonstrieren sie vor der russischen
Botschaft weil die Schutz macht sie
fallen gelassen hat ausgerechnet heute
beginnt das Land seine Unabhängigkeit
von der Sowjetunion die ihnen gerade
jetzt wohl schmerzlich bewusst sein
dürfte der Regierungschef dessen am
seidenen Faden hängt rechtfertigt sich
der Weg zum Frieden ist nicht einfach er
führt über äußere und innere
Erschütterungen doch wir müssen diesen
Weg gehen für unsere Unabhängigkeit
unseren Staat und unsere Zukunft die
karabach-armenia erwähnte in seiner Rede
gar nicht sie haben keine Fürsprecher
mehr so sieht das aus wenn ein Staat der
niemals existieren sollte abgewickelt
wird
heute ist Weltfriedenstag aber von
Weltfrieden sind wir leider meilenweit
entfernt stattdessen Krieg und Kämpfe
und damit Gundula beginnen jetzt auch
deine Nachrichten die Ukraine hat nach
eigenen Angaben einen russischen
Militärflugplatz auf der Krim massiv
angegriffen und schwer beschädigt nach
der völkerrechtswidrigen Annexion von
2014 will die ukrainische Führung auch
die Krim zurückerobern zugleich hat das
russische Militär erneut die ukrainische
Hauptstadt Kiew massiv aus der Luft
angegriffen mehrere Menschen wurden
verletzt in herson kamen fünf Menschen
ums Leben
Syriens macht aber Assad ist erstmals
seit fast 20 Jahren zu einem offiziellen
Besuch in China eingetroffen es gehe
darum die Beziehungen auf eine neue
Ebene zu heben so dass chinesische
Außenministerium beobachte erwarten dass
er sagt in China um finanzielle Hilfe
beim Wiederaufbau seines durch den
Bürgerkrieg zerstörten Landes bitten
will auch ein Treffen mit Chinas
Präsident hi ist geplant
Bildungserfolge unabhängig von sozialer
Herkunft das ist das Ziel des geplanten
startchancenprogramms Bundesregierung
und Länder haben sich jetzt auf
Eckpunkte verständigt damit sollen
Schulen mit vielen sozial
benachteiligten Kindern und Jugendlichen
mit zwei Milliarden Euro pro Jahr
unterstützt werden diese zusätzliche
Förderung kommt laut
Bundesbildungsministerin stark Watzinger
4.000 Schulen mit rund einer Millionen
Schülern zugute am Rande der
Agrarministerkonferenz von Bund und
Ländern haben hunderte Landwirte Fischer
und Waldbesitzer gegen die Politik von
bundeslandwirtschaftsminister mir
protestiert sie warfen ihn
Blockadehaltung vor dem Gesetze auf
Ordnungsrecht und Auflagen das aber
schaffe nicht mehr Tierwohl sondern
führe dazu dass billiges Fleisch aus dem
Ausland importiert werde mir hingegen
war für seine Pläne für mehr Tierschutz
eigentlich sind die Deutschen anderen
Völkern von Natur aus überlegen es gibt
wertvolles und unwertes Leben der
Nationalsozialismus hatte auch seine
guten Seiten Diktatur ist mitunter die
beste Staatsform wir sollten einen
Führer haben der Deutschland zum Wohle
aller mit starker Hand regiert Aussagen
bei denen man denken würde dass nahezu
jeder in unserem Land diese verneinen
würde aber die neue mittelstudie belegt
etwas anderes so teilt jede zwölfte
Person in Deutschland inzwischen ein
rechtsextremes Weltbild Bernd Benthin
das Rechtsextremismus stärker in die
Gesellschaft einsickert beobachtet er
schon seit langem Dominik Schumacher ist
Bundessprecher der mobilen Beratung
gegen Rechtsextremismus erklärt auf
versucht zu verhindern und schaut
besorgt auf einen Drift ins Extreme wir
machen auch diese Erfahrung dass
beratungsnehmende die wir vorher dazu
beraten haben wie sie gegen
Rechtsextremismus insgesamt aktiv werden
können sich nun vermehrt mit der Frage
auseinandersetzen müssen wie gehe ich
damit um ganz persönlich von
Rechtsextremisten angefeinde zu werden
das heißt also auch zum Beispiel bei mir
zu Hause im Betrieb in der Schule
überall nur jeder zweite vertraut den
staatlichen Institutionen rechtsextreme
Einstellungen nehmen stark zu zu diesen
Ergebnissen kommt die aktuelle Mitte
Studie im Auftrag der
Friedrich-Ebert-Stiftung vor zwei Jahren
noch hätten zwei bis drei Prozent
rechtsextreme Ansichten geteilt jetzt
seines 8%, 6 % in den alten und 16% in
den neuen Bundesländern was unsere Daten
zeigen ich glaube sie zeigen dass die
Mitte sich tatsächlich in Teilen auf
Distanz zu Demokratie begeben hat ein
Teilen hat sie sich radikalisiert was
Deutschland jetzt braucht ist eine
einzige starke Partei die die
Volksgemeinschaft insgesamt verkörpert
überwiegend oder voll und ganz stimmen
dem
23,9% der Befragten zu die
Bundesrepublik ist durch die vielen
Ausländer in einem gefährlichen Maß über
fremdet dem Stimmen 27,8% überwiegend
oder voll zu
auch antidemokratische Einstellungen
nehmen zu Ablehnung gegen Parteien und
Politik die regierenden Parteien
betrügen das Volk das Sagen 29,7%
einige Politiker haben es verdient wenn
die Wut gegen Sie schon einmal in schon
mal in Gewalt umschlägt nur als Beispiel
dem Stimmen 13% zu wir erleben auf
kommunaler Ebene das leider Gottes die
Zahl der Bedrohungen Beleidigungen bis
hin zu tätlichen Übergriffen gegenüber
Bürgermeisterin Bürgermeister aber auch
gegen Mitarbeitenden in den Verwaltungen
in den vergangenen Jahren deutlich
zugenommen hat und das ist eine
besorgniserregende Entwicklung insofern
besteht dass die Ergebnisse der Studie
auch nach Gründen für diese Zahlen sucht
die Studie verantwortlich sei die
Vielzahl an Krisen aber auch ein
Grundgefühl der Einsamkeit in einer
zunehmend zersplitterten Gesellschaft
der bei manchen Menschen gibt es ja die
Überzeugung dass man in Deutschland
nicht mehr alles sagen könne bzw gleich
als rechtsextrem gilt wenn man nicht dem
linken dem voken oder Mainstream Lager
angehört und die ziehen dann auch solche
Studien in Zweifel fragen wir nach bei
Beate Küpper sie ist sozialpsychologin
und Mitautorin der Studie einen schönen
guten Abend nach Berlin guten Abend was
ist denn für sie der Indikator dass
jemand eine extremistische Meinung oder
ein extremistisches Weltbild hat also
die mittelstudie erfasst rechtsextreme
Einstellung nach einer sogenannten
Konsensus Definition auf die sich
etliche Wissenschaftlerinnen und
Wissenschaftler vor einigen Jahren
geeinigt haben und das sind drei
politische historische Dimensionen
beispielsweise Befürwortung einer
Diktatur die Verharmlosung des
Nationalsozialismus oder nationaler
Chauvinismus und drei völkisch soziale
Dimension fremfeindlichkeit
Antisemitismus und sozial Darwinismus
und all das sind
Dimensionen die ganz Kleinen nicht im
Sinne unseres Grundgesetzes und unsere
liberalen Demokratie sind
dann noch mal nachgefragt gelten denn
heute Aussagen als radikal oder
extremistisch die vor sagen wir mal 20
oder 30 Jahren anders bewertet wurden
also hat sich der sogenannte
meinungskorridor wirklich verengt
ich weiß so ich sag mal salopp dahin
gesagt ein Vorurteilen mag das der Fall
sein bei diesen harten rechtsextremen
Aussagen nicht der Nationalsozialismus
hat auch seine guten Seite dass es
unzweifelhaft rechtsextrem des
Gedankengut und das war auch schon vor
20 Jahren so es gibt wie lebenswertes
und unwertes Leben auch das ist eine
Aussage die auch schon vor 20 Jahren als
nicht grundgesetzkonforme gelten hätte
wie erklären sie sich denn dann dass
Menschen die sich zum Beispiel eher dem
linken Spektrum oder aber auch der Mitte
zuordnen laut ihrer Studie ein
rechtsextremes Gedankengut oder Weltbild
in sich tragen nun ja das eine ist die
politische selbstverordnung wo sehe ich
mich auf dem Spektrum von links Mitte
rechts selber und das andere ist welche
Einstellungen habe ich da und da sehen
wir zweierlei wir haben wir haben
erstens Menschen die ganz der fest davon
überzeugt sind dass so das was sie
meinen Mitte ist weil sie vielleicht in
einer Umgebung wohnen wo man das meint
wo sie viele Freunde und Bekannte haben
das gleiche meinen sie fühlen sich also
als Mitte und die Behauptung Mitte zu
sein ist natürlich auch eine ein
politisches Statement und auch ein
Versuch die Mitte nach rechts zurück
indem man nämlich sagt das was ich meine
ist einfach normal richtig also Mitte
deswegen heißt ihre Studie ja auch die
distanzierte Mitte welches Ergebnis ist
im Sinne einer offenen Liberalen und
pluralistischen Gesellschaft das wo sie
aufgehorcht haben oder wo sie sagen das
hat sich stark verändert
der dramatische Anstieg tatsächlich
alles geschlossen rechtsextremen
Weltbildes das ist etwas was wir in
dieser Dramatik ist es nicht ganz
unerwartet aber in dieser drastisch
Anstieg nicht erwartet hätten wir haben
fast dreimal so hohe Zahlen wie noch vor
zwei Jahren und deutlich höhere Zahl als
all in den Jahren in den letzten Jahren
zuvor das ist tatsächlich etwas wir
haben 8,3% der Befragten die tatsächlich
ein geschlossenen rechtsextremes Bild
haben und wir haben weitere fast 20
Prozent die sich in so einem Graubereich
bewegen das sind also Menschen die nicht
kein Rechtsextremismus Weltbild haben
die aber auch nicht klar demokratisch
sind sondern sie so ein bisschen
ambivalent sind die ein bisschen teils
Teil sind die also auch ein bisschen
teils teils sagen naja vielleicht
brauchen wir einen starken Führer der
Deutschland mit starker Hand regiert
also das ist tatsächlich etwas was uns
besorgt hat und das weitere was uns
besorgt hat sind die hohen Anstiege bei
den jungen Leuten lange war es so dass
ältere Menschen eher
Demokratie gefährdende Einstellung
beispielsweise auch antisemitische
Einstellung hatten das hat sich geändert
wir haben hohe Werte der Verharmlosung
des Nationalsozialismus des
Antisemitismus und des Sozialdarwinismus
gerade bei den 18 bis 35-Jährigen was
sind denn die Gründe dafür also ist es
die Unsicherheit durch multiple
Herausforderung allein das kann es doch
nicht sein es ist beides wir haben auf
eine auf der einen Seite haben wir diese
multiplen Krisenlagen die auch als
krisenhaft erlebt werden dabei ist es
interessant nur ein Drittel sagt ich bin
persönlich von der Krise betroffen aber
deutlich mehr als die Hälfte sagt
Deutschland ist von der Krise betroffen
und da fängt es dann an schwer greifbar
zu werden auch politisch schwer greifbar
zu werden und das ist dann das
Einfallstor für den Populismus wir
können sehen dass diejenigen die sich
von der Krise dann auch verunsichert
fühlen deutlich eher dann auch zu
anti-demokratischen ich sag mal
angeboten greifen und er auch Demokratie
feindlich ein bisschen zu Gewalt
billigende Einstellung haben also
komplett komplexe Fragen einfache
Lösungen die Formel des Populismus alles
in allem können Sie festmachen was
helfen würde also gegen die
Radikalisierung gegen
verschwörungspraktika gegen die
Polarisierung gegen den
Rechtsextremismus was braucht es also es
braucht mehr Aufmerksamkeit für
diejenigen die Sorge haben dass uns die
Demokratie unter den Fingern zerbröselt
die sich tagtäglich demokratisch für die
Demokratie engagieren die sich
tagtäglich auch für andere engagieren
die brauchen deutlich mehr
Aufmerksamkeit das ist nach wie vor die
große Mehrheit und ein wenig weniger
Aufmerksamkeit für diejenigen die die
Demokratie verachten sagt Beate Küpper
mit Autorin der mittelstudie vielen Dank
für Ihre Zeit ich danke Ihnen
und das Gespräch haben wir am Abend
aufgezeichnet jetzt geht es hier erstmal
weiter mit Gundula und der Wirtschaft
aktuell sind die Preise für Gas und
Strom gesunken trotzdem mehren sich die
Forderungen die preisbremsen zumindest
bis Ende April zu verlängern auch
Finanzminister Lindner befürwortet das
Valerie Halle er will aber zugleich die
Anhebung der Mehrwertsteuer auf Gas
vorziehen was bedeutet das alles für die
Verbraucher ja eine zusätzliche
Belastung würde das bedeuten dass
Finanzministerium rechnet damit dass
seine vorgezogene Mehrwertsteuererhöhung
rund 2 Milliarden Euro in die Kassen
spülen würde verbraucher müssten sich
also vermutlich auf deutlich höhere
Kosten einstellen zu früh und unerwartet
kritisieren Verbraucherschützer zumal
die Erhöhung in die Heizperiode fallen
würde auch innerhalb der Ampel ist die
Anhebung umstritten die
gaspreisbremse zu verlängern dürfte der
Regierung in das leichter fallen die hat
den Staat laut einer Schätzung des
ifo-Instituts bislang weit wenig
gekostet als gedacht weil die Gaspreise
ebenso deutlich gefallen sind wie ist es
denn um die Gasversorgung bestellt wie
sicher ist die wenn der Winter kalt wird
die Bundesnetzagentur die ja die
Gasversorgung im Blick hat meint wir
sind gut aufgestellt für den Winter
besser als im Jahr zuvor die deutschen
Speicher sein gut gefüllt die Behörde
führt das unter anderem darauf zurück
dass Industrie und Haushalte deutlich
weniger Gas verbraucht hätten etwa 20
Prozent das ist laut Behörde auch weiter
wichtig denn wenn der Winter sehr kalt
wird steigt der Gasverbraucher Sand für
eine Entwarnung ist es der
Bundesnetzagentur also noch zu früh
vielen Dank Valerie nach Frankfurt
wir haben zwei Ergebnisse von
internationalen Fußballwettbewerben
Bayer Leverkusen ist gegen den
schwedischen Fußballmeister BK Hecken in
die Europa League gestartet und hat die
Party gewonnen 4:0 und eintracht
Frankfurt hat zum Auftakt in der
Konferenz liegt Gruppenphase gegen den
FC Aberdeen aus Schottland ebenfalls
gewonnen 2:1
am zweiten Tag seines Staatsbesuchs in
Frankreich hat der britische König
Charles III im Senat für gemeinsame
Maßnahmen zum Klimaschutz geworben
Briten und Franzosen könnten
partnerschaftlich die Herausforderungen
dieser Welt meisten es gehe darum Klima
und Natur vor katastrophale Zerstörung
zu bewahren erklärte König Charles seine
Naturverbundenheit zeigte er auch mit
dem Besuch eines Pariser Blumenmarktes
der nach seiner Mutter Elisabeth II
benannt ist
ZDF in ist ein Format bei dem Kollegen
oder Kolleginnen in eine Stadt
eintauchen für vier Wochen um dort am
Alltagsleben teilzunehmen Karin
henkemann und Ralf Zimmermann von
Siefert sind in Hamburg unterwegs
konkret auf St Pauli also zwischen
Partymeile und Prostitution
Gentrifizierung und Obdachlosigkeit
sozialen Engagement und Show und von
dieser Show gibt es aktuell noch mehr
als sonst denn zur Zeit findet dort
eines der größten Club Festivals Europa
statt
Stimmung ist alles beim Reeperbahn
Festival mit den Bazookas zum Beispiel
aus den Niederlanden das Publikum als
Teil der Performance wenn der Schulbus
gerockt wird schon seit 18 Jahren ist
das Hamburger happening erster Adresse
für junge Musik und woanders könnte das
stattfinden als auf St Pauli es ist
längst auch für die weltweite
Musikbranche ein etabliertes treffen das
bedeutendste europäische überhaupt viele
von denen die es schon geschafft haben
offen für neue Inspiration was werden ja
auch Ideen geboren gemeinsam
Netzwerken connecten ist sehr wichtig
und ich finde es passt wunderbar zu
Hamburg weil Hamburg hat so ein bisschen
was zwischen Straßenkatzen Dreck und
Klammer und da muss sehr lange
Musikgeschichte für mich als Hamburger
das ist immer da war immer auf einmal da
war und für mich ist es jetzt zum ersten
Mal richtig bewusst da weil ich zum
ersten Teil davon sein darf
neue Künstler zu beurteilen und zu sehen
was gerade ist in der jungen Zähne
ist das Reeperbahn Festival tatsächlich
auch was für ältere Herren
[Gelächter]
was machst du besonders dass hier so
viele junge Leute sind das ist toll
nee aber es gibt ganz viel zu entdecken
neue Künstler und gute Konzerte also das
ist super spannend einfach
amerikanische Künstlerinnen die inico
sind es die das Reeperbahn Festival
bereichern eine echte Social Media
Königin mit 2 Millionen verloren
ich bin das erste Mal in Deutschland und
aufgeregt das erste Mal auf einem roten
Teppich zu stehen
oder aluparks eine 23-jährige Britin
deren Konzerte weltweit bereits
ausverkauft sind
es ist wunderbar es geht hier ums
entdecken und um die Diversität in der
die neue und die etablierte Szene aus
der ganzen Welt zusammenkommt
an den ungewöhnlichsten Orten 70 an der
Zahl mit fast 500 Konzerten Bands und
Künstlerinnen aus 50 Ländern verteilt
über ganz St Pauli in Clubs und Kneipen
das Reeperbahn Festival hat hier auch
sonst ein echtes zu Hause
wenn wir sagen hamburg ist eine
Musikstadt dann hat das wesentlich was
mit St Pauli und dieser Dichte anklubs
zu tun man geht durch diesen Stadtteil
und quasi aus jedem Haus kommt Musik und
das ist wirklich was was es kaum so auf
der Welt noch mal gibt so ist das
Hamburger Rotlicht und Partyviertel für
vier Tage im musikalischen
Ausnahmezustand nicht nur mit Musikern
sondern eben auch mit Musikliebhabern
aus aller Welt und aus allen
Altersgruppen St Pauli eben wie es
bleibt und lebt
lebendig dürfte jetzt auch die
Diskussion bei Maybrit Illner werden ist
diskutieren unter anderem
Innenministerin Phaser und Jens Spahn
von der CDU über die Frage zu viele zu
schnell lässt sich Migration begrenzen
und um 0:35 Uhr meldet sich nah sein
Glück bei mir mit unserem heute journal
Update das war's von uns machen sie es
gut wo auch immer sie sind tschüß
schönen Abend
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter heute war
Nordeuropa und Südeuropa miteinander
verbunden mit dieser Kaltfront und mit
einem beinahe durchgehenden Regenwand
von Norwegen bis nach Spanien dahinter
sehen wir diese streuselkuchenartige
Wirkung das ist die Kaltluft die dafür
sorgen wird dass es kühler wird und so
sieht es auf dem Vorschau Film aus wir
haben es hier mit einem Regenbogen zu
tun da sind Gewitter eingelagert in den
nächsten Stunden gibt's noch einige und
in der zweiten Nachthälfte sieht das
allmählich ostwärts ab und morgen im
Tagesverlauf dann raus aus Deutschland
im Süden regnet es weiter und vor allem
hier im alten Brand sogar kräftig ja und
in der Nacht also hier noch letzte
Schauer und Gewitter in der Mitte und
dann wird es allmählich nach Osten hin
weniger Temperaturen die gehen zurück
auf 9 Grad ganz im Westen Deutschlands
und 16 bis 17 Grad im Osten hier ist es
noch relativ nett
morgen dann im Osten noch Schauer die
ziehen allmählich ab im Süden regnet es
dann länger anhaltend ja dazwischen gibt
es hier einige Auflockerungen der Mitte
mit Sonnenschein ansonsten kommt zum
Nachmittag neue Schauer im Nordwesten
und ganz im Westen auch einzelne
Gewitter Aufbau höchsten Temperaturen
von 21 Grad im Osten 22 Grad am
Oberrhein aber oft liegen wir unter der
20 Grad Marke ja die nächsten Tage
werden schon wieder sonniger Samstag
hier noch einige Schauer und Montag bis
24 Grad fahren damit ein schöner Abend